your call is important to us so please
all the line and an Apple representative
well provide assistance hi do you guys
have any iPhones we don't have any and
stuff right now no you're not oh we're
sold out at the moment no we don't hold
up play no we're sold out tonight
we're all out stop they had them earlier
we actually just recently ran out now we
sold out today we ran out around three
o'clock we are sold out right now
yes sir return we're out of stock of
this we don't have any iPhone no we sold
out today we do not today we're all sold
out Rekha's sold out don't think we have
enough um glasses past this hour
right now we're pulled out no we do not
yeah we'll have any more left by the
time the line is done
no we don't have any I funky stuff right
now why is Steve doing this this is
torture it's Steve Jobs it's okay I know
I hear ya oh sure you're completely out
none oh oh a limited supply of the white
16-gigabyte available really oh my god
Oh another Kelly I think we have only
enough for the people who have been
waiting in line all day what was the
song that was on the hold music oh okay
I was dancing sorry okay thank you
are you bye you guys have people calling
constantly oh my gosh okay well thank
you all right bye